you ever have one of those thoughts that
are real and true but feel weird I know
I have a question demo okay so when I
playing the game well I came out of
there
that's crazy my mom's a good 3d printer
a friend and I were recently having a
conversation about a boy in her life and
you know no matter how articulate poised
and intelligent you are when you're
excited for your friend we all react the
same but as the conversation got deeper
into the potential of a relationship
with this guy we somehow came upon this
thought you know the best-case scenario
is you meet the perfect partner and then
you die or he dies because statistically
women are likely to live longer yeah and
then you're forced to live out the rest
of your lives totally alone never able
to rekindle that romance with anyone
else
I mean sure maybe you might meet someone
else but how could that possibly live up
to the life of friendship love and
connection with the one that you lost
and you're just dead in the void the end
yeah that's the best-case scenario and I
know that seems depressing but we found
it oddly comforting you know because it
suddenly takes a lot of the pressure off
it's like a free pass to not take
everything so seriously
to alleviate yourself from some
suffering and it just gives yourself
permission to enjoy the moment but then
again we're a very unique because our
friendship motto is we all die and
nothing matters
so if you're like me and I've spent the
majority of your life placing a priority
on love and finding a partner which i
think is like 99% of us to be fair just
remember the best case scenario still
ends the same way
as the worst case scenario you die alone
so I'm gonna make it more of a priority
to just try and connect with people in
the moment to have fun and to deepen my
friendships with the people who inspire
me and then someday if I'm lucky I'm
Anna Akana
stay right here for a sponsored message
from audible thank you to audible for
sponsoring today's episode audiobooks
are perfect for summer activities like
hiking sunbathing on the beach or road
tripping I've been currently listening
to how to be an adult in relationships
by david Rico because it was recommended
by one of you guys and I found it to be
very insightful about how to approach
romantic relationships with respect
compassion and a genuine desire to
understand where the other person is
coming from audible numbers get a credit
every month regardless of price and
unused credits roll over to the next
month if you don't like your audiobook
don't worry you can always exchange it
no questions asked
go to audible.com slash Ana for text Ana
to 500 500
to get a free audiobook with a 30-day
free trial that's a you di ble comm
slash Ana or text Ana to 500 500